comme anna une bonne douche vous êtes
déjà venu ici au ben non c'est
l'affluence est une date nous avons
l'aîné des capétiens aux bars et les
pubs
bonsoir florence bonsoir f24 bonsoir je
vous présente michael del mar qui
commence aujourd'hui dans bad minuit et
qui va faire des interviews astral les
astros view à partir du thème astral de
nos de nous inviter à l'oref de castro
publiées chez orban un livre qui
s'appelle les bâtards du soleil qui fait
450 pages donc croire et si je dis je
dois en parler oui je rêve de partir en
vacances pour le lire alors vous avez
vous à nous expliquer qu'il y ait le duc
d'anjou parce que si moi je l'expliquais
madère chute parti pris le duc d'anjou
est le descendant en ligne directe de la
branche légitime de louis xiv c'est à
dire que louis xiv a eu un fils mon
seigneur qui a eu lui même trois fils
dont le second le duc d'anjou philippe
duc d'anjou est devenu roi d'espagne
jean philippe cinq ans selon deux
finissent 5es monseigneur descendent de
ceux du camping est aujourd'hui le plus
proche parent de louis xiv au monde
absolument pas vous connaissez bien
ça c'est le moindre des choses c'est la
moindre des choses alors vous êtes
intéressez vous aux bâtards de louis xiv
oui je me suis intéressé aux bâtards
parce que personne depuis saint simon ne
s'était jamais intéressé et ça m'avait
un peu intrigué après une lecture au
classique de saint simon qui faisait du
duc du maine notamment qu'on connaît
bien à travers lui un portrait
dramatique épouvantable méprisable en
peu de choses et je me suis penché de
plus près sur ses personnages et j'ai
découvert des gens fascinants
je ne dirais pas des gens merveilleux ni
des gens admirables mais des gens par
bien des côtés très attachant parce que
très haut en couleur tout à fait
conforme à l'esprit de leur siècle c'est
à 10
excessif à la fois extrêmement toute
chose je sais je sais pas bien comment
vous le détailler mais capable du
meilleur comme du pire ça c'est certain
capable de maisons eu plein de problèmes
parce que l'on était légitimé par louis
xiv et puis ensuite une fois que louis
xiv est mort lors à retirer leurs
privilèges et leurs avantages c'est du
vivant de leur père ils ont été vraiment
considérés comme les premiers
personnages à la cour parce que louis
xiv à utiliser pour faire contrepoint
aller plus à la puissance des princes de
son sang qui s'était réjoui qui s'était
révolté contre l'autorité royale du
temps de la fronde donc à chacun des
héritiers de ses trois branches fondeuse
orléans condé et conti il a donnée en
mariage un bâtard ou une bataille c'est
à dire les fils de la vallière et de
montespan de manière à abâtardir
justement ces trois branches la de façon
à ce que seule la descendance du dauphin
ou de monseigneur soit actuellement
purent alors vous avez vu le succès les
livres consacrés consacré au roi en ce
moment non plus chez un a vendu combien
de sang louis xiv oui j'ai entendu dire
que son lit va passer les 100 minutes en
moi j'ai vu quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup étonné c'est une pièce de 10
francs ou pour la première fois d'un
côté il ya là il ya la devise de la
république et de l'autre côté il ya un
roi c'est quand même très étonnant ça
quand même
est ce que vous savez ce que ça signifie
pas pour vous
un changement finalement de mentalité en
france
je pense que c'est le succès du
millénaire capétiens qui finalement
représente quand même beaucoup pour
l'année dernière il ya eu un sondage
dans le poing brandi et que 18% des
franchises des français étaient
favorables à un retour de la monarchie
oui je les goûts ça m'a l'air très à
glaire ça vous fait plaisir
monseigneur vous êtes de nationalité
espagnole n'est-ce pas gênant quand on
se veut le prétendant au trône de france
mais moi je ne me veut absolument rien
du tout je me suis fait avoir je ne suis
que l'aîné les capétiens
mais vous considérez que vos droits sont
plus légitimes que ceux par exemple de
la famille du comte de paris ça il
suffit de regarder dans la logique de
voir à mon avis c'est très simple je
suis l'aîné et selon les lois
fondamentales
c'est l'aîné qui compte et tandis que
les orléans c'est une branche cadette et
qui comme tout le monde sait et
descendant de philippe égalité qui a
voté la mort de l'ue 16 par deux fois et
et qui ont usurpé le troll en 1830 avec
louis philippe donc vous briguez en
aucun cas la couronne de france
ce moment j'ai l'impression que la
colonne aime bien gardé et pas une
république qui a un président à la tête
monseigneur est ce qu'on se retrouve pas
aujourd'hui dans une situation en france
avec un finalement on pourrait dire le
comte de paris et vous un roi de droite
en roi de gauche est-ce que c'est pas
très français ça allait les gens de
droite préfèrent le duc d'anjou et les
gens de gauche préférerait le le comte
de paris est ce que c'est pas un peu
dommage savez je pense que d'état droite
et à gauche
aujourd'hui ne représente pas beaucoup
je pense que en europe occidentale
l'histologie sont totalement permet donc
la disposition au parlement à droite et
à gauche était en fonction de ce qui
s'est passé
au début du siècle passé en 80 le comte
de paris a appelé à voter françois
mitterrand et vous en 88 bien que vous
ne votez pas qu'ils soutiendraient vous
alors raymond barre jacques chirac
françois mitterrand michel rocard je ne
vais pas commettre l'inter de dire pour
qui je voterai si j'allais voter
de toute façon je ne suis évidemment pas
la république donc je ne vais pas voter
pour le président des riches
qu'est ce que vous allez vous opposer
comme certains monarchiste le prévoit au
bicentenaire de la révolution française
par quelques déclarations quelques
manifestations
non je ne pense pas de gym opposé mais
il est certain que une commémoration qui
a divisé d'une façon sanglante les
français il ya 200 ans se répéter de
l'idéal de commémorer d'autres choses
qui les réunissent donc c'est peut-être
pas la commémoration de la révolution
française qui serait l'idéal pour
lumière les français je pense qu'il ya
énormément d'autres dates qui sont
importantes et qui certainement nice
beaucoup plus le français que ces dates
après le mot monarchie quel est celui
que vous préférez il n'y a pas de
mouvement que je peux pas faire lorsque
après le moins monarchie quel est celui
que vous préférez
ben je pense que même avant le moment la
chine j'aime l'humanité jeunes êtres
humains c'est skip je pense est la chose
la plus importante
la monarchie n'est qu'une partie de
cette humanité c'est une façon de
gouverner c'est humanité il faudra
fonctionner bien fonctionné dans cinq
pays dont doutent pas alors maintenant
on va passer à michael d'al-ahmar qui a
étudié le thème astral de monseigneur à
partir donc exactement du lieu de
naissance de la date de naissance de
leurs deux naissances
alors est ce que tu vois dans les astres
est ce que tu vois un rétablissement
possible de la monarchie dans les années
qui viennent
non ça c'est peut-être aller un peu loin
mais je pense que pour monseigneur le
liban joue 1994 pourrait être donnée
importante à mesure vous
en juin 94 le soleil progresser transit
le lunaire nord dans sa maison dix et
pour lui ça pourrait représenter 1
comment dirais-je à un achèvement en
accomplissement dans sa carrière le cas
dans son milieu socioprofessionnel
ingénieurs votre métier le seigneur mais
en tout cas ce pourrait être une étape
importante tous méfier parce que moi
même avait dit à 10 ans les dix ans je
le connais il m'avait dit que je ferais
la télévision dans dix ans donc
effectivement 1,94 ça représente quand
même le l'échéance électorale
présidentielle
la prochaine wii la halle celle d'après
alors est-ce que ce thème astral
t'inspire d'autres questions à michael
oui oui en fait j'aimerais demander à
mon seigneur quand est ce qu'ils se sont
le plus toro plutôt réputé être un signe
instinctif primaire parfois enfantin et
j'aimerais savoir quand est-ce que vous
vous sentez le plus confirmé par le site
du trou et je suis venu vous êtes
taureau je suis j'ai toujours pensé que
j'étais billets y avait ce que je suis
d'arriver à révéler ce que le dernier
délai à 0° 8 euros en vertu votre heure
de naissance 16h à rome vous êtes toro à
sondernach un bon voilà alors vous
viviez comme un bellier j'ai toujours
pensé que j'étais fini alors établi un
plan butoir mais vous allez c'est pas
rien deuxième question
deuxième question j'avais envie de
demander à mon seigneur en vertu du
trigone fallait jupiter ça c'est du vent
je voulais savoir ils se sentent est
très attiré par le côté représentation
d'entre nous voit beaucoup en ce moment
je voulais savoir si c'est un job vous
appuierez de représenter quelque chose
d'autre
oui je pense que c'est plutôt
à cause du fait que je m'appelle
mouvement que je suis l'aîné
on s'est mis les nerfs capétiens des
capétiens donc des poupons c'est quelque
chose d'absolument l'actuel disons que
si j'étais né
monsieur durand je n'essayerai pas de
déficit la chronique et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous mettez un peu de bleu